on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
tonight on piers morgan unsensitive with
me jeremy cal back soon act or trust in
trust we're here live from both front
runners to be britain's next prime
minister the heat is on in britain's
heat wave but millions then face having
to switch it off this winter tonight
we'll take on the utilities crisis plus
as the fbi sensationally raids president
trump's florida estate i'm joined live
in the studio by his former senior
advisor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends welcome to piers
morgan uncensored i'm jeremy carlin
later on more from those tory hustings
in darlington with leadership candidates
rishi sunek and liz trust but first
tonight let's talk water drains gas
electricity heating these of course the
basic things we all need to exist in our
homes the fact that we have them for me
is the most basic mark of living in a
developed country so what does it say
about the uk in 2022 that for millions
of people access to them is now
seriously under threat you'll have heard
me say hose pipes will be banned perhaps
until october families are being ordered
to take shorter showers and turn off the
taps whilst brushing their nashes they
tell me there's a drought and sure it's
hot but there was no drought in north
london yesterday as a burst water main
turn this street into a boating lake and
i have to say i don't think there'll be
a drought if the uk's nine water
companies didn't waste check this 3.2
billion liters of water in leaks just
like that one in london they waste that
every single day and those same failing
companies by the way paid out 48 million
quid to their execs in the last two
years including unbelievably 27 million
quid in bonuses we wrote this these
aren't fat cats they're water rats
see when the summer honestly when the
summer sun subsides the real coming
storm is going to be the cost of
energies now prices already already have
rocketed last october the bill for a
typical household in the uk covered by
that price cap was one thousand two
hundred and seventy seven quid six
months later by april this year that are
rocketed to almost two thousand pounds
and look at this by october it's now
expected to be what can only be
described as a ridiculous
3500 quid today we find out by next
january this could hit 4 200 pounds that
is for every family 355
quid a month quick memo from this show
to energy bosses it's supposed to be a
price cap not a target we have really
grim choices ahead and i think for many
people they're thinking what are we
going to do about it today labour's
angel arena put the absolute blame front
and center on the government's inaction
i think it's disgraceful that boris
johnson as the prime minister has said
it's not my responsibility anymore he
said he needed to carry on until
september well where are you how dare
you let people down when they need you
so much they voted and elected for you
and you just literally laughed at them
when they need your support right now i
think it's absolutely disgraceful and
shows you the difference between gordon
brown as the prime minister who has come
out now and said we need to do something
urgently to help people and the current
prime minister who says
not my problem
gotta say you agree with reina there you
know our government seems to have
disappeared we're a rudderless ship i'm
joined now by financial expert every
night this week gemma godfrey along with
former chief executive of energy uk
angela knight um actually let's start
with you angela um
i i've tried since the first day to put
this in layman's terms there are
millions of people the length and
breadth of this country who will see
their energy bills rise by what three
thousand pounds a year
all we hear is figures and excuses uh
the supply is less because of russia you
know french reactors how is it in 2022
angela knight that massive companies can
report billions of pounds worth of
profit and not be forced by the
government or other people to give that
back to the consumers because i don't
understand it and nor do the people
watching this program tonight
no i agree with you it's a very
difficult situation that we're in and
whether we like it or not we're caught
in a world problem the companies that
have been making a lot of money are
those who take who
take the oil and the gas out of the
ground
and they've got a certain amount of
fixed cost and at the moment what
they're seeing is huge prices that
they're being able to get for their oil
and gas because the global market the
wholesale market is as high as it is
we buy as as you know domestic consumers
our gas and electricity from suppliers
they're not really the drillers but i
think that the point is a very valid one
and that is you know who should be
contributing to assisting people and
particularly those who are on the
poorest incomes and uh pensioners and i
do know that first of all the gas and
the oil companies that which they you
know pull out here in the the uk and
where we've we're able to get at them
from tax purposes uh we're making them
pay about 40 percent
uh corporation tax at the moment rising
to 65 percent so between two and three
times the tax at normal companies
so there is something that is being done
but angela that's all well and good and
i go back to what i said at the
beginning you said there that they get
the people that take the the electricity
and the gas out to fix their cost
i don't believe that morally that is
right i believe that any business
survives because of its customers what
you are going to have in the united
kingdom are millions of people who
literally cannot afford to pay this ever
increasing bill as a business you would
think they would go well we're going to
lose all our customers so why don't we
for example i mean you saw me i don't
know if you heard me 48 billion in
bonuses and wages to nine water
companies 3.2 trillion
water leaks a day or so it's utterly
ludicrous for people watching this
program to think how can i stump up my
bill when i'm getting nothing i'll bring
in gemma godfrey with us all week do you
understand people's frustration jim yeah
what happened was the government
had a winful tax to try and make sure
that more money was coming from the
energy providers that were making lots
of money but then they also gave them a
rebate and said but actually if you
invest in your own growth ideally
renewable but if you invest in that then
actually you don't have to pay it so so
actually it was also quite a lot and it
isn't reaching people isn't actually
helping people and what we also saw is a
lot of small supplies and i agree we're
not talking about the drill is here the
suppliers but still a lot of the smaller
suppliers still went bust because they
couldn't make
it at that end as well which means that
when people go online and they try and
find more deals there aren't as much
deals
over the last 12 months whenever i've
talked about another living crisis we
talk about people who are are struggling
uh people are on benefit
i'm always quite fixated on what we call
jams which is the just about managing
the people who don't get a handout from
anybody the people who work around the
clock probably got a couple of kids they
pay all their bills they get absolutely
no support i i want somebody to say to
me if if that family can't afford four
thousand two hundred pounds what's going
to happen their credit line will be
destroyed they'll be evicted what why
aren't companies saying unless we now
why aren't the government saying you've
made all that profit give it back to the
consumer to sustain the business long
term i know and what they've done is
they said fine we're going to give
families 400 pounds that's the payment
that people are going to get in october
and that's not enough and to say to
people oh you know take a shower rather
than a bath that'll save what pen is
pounds
increase by thousands this 400 quid if i
can bring angela back in if that's okay
um this 400 pound is that across the
board is that is that for every single
person in the united kingdom is that the
government's idea right
jeremy's household and by the way i'm
not here to defend energy companies i'm
not here to defend water companies i'm
here to try and give a little bit more
information which i hope will be helpful
for what is for all of us i entirely
agree a very difficult situation what i
do expect i mean by the way that 400
pounds of course if you're in
more difficulties you do get more than
that 400 pounds what i'm expecting to
see is another round of assistance that
will start to be talked about towards
the end of this month and beginning of
september because whilst it's entirely
correct that you know there's a
leadership election taking place and i
absolutely agree with people that is not
helpful at the same time there's still a
lot of ministers in their roles there's
still a lot of civil servants in there
working and what will be happening as i
know from the days when i was a a junior
minister junior i say unfortunately you
know wasn't a senior one i was left with
all the all the all the bad gigs to do
but certainly when i was there and it's
exactly the same to this day what is
happening is that there will be a lot of
options being worked up and worked
through yeah so when this leadership
election is through then there's not
just choices and you think oh well what
do i do there's choices there which are
known what they're going to cost who who
is going to benefit and also and very
importantly how to put them into
operation because that is vital it's no
use saying jam tomorrow because tomorrow
never comes i i really agree the engine
i think gemma would as well i mean i
don't know anybody by the way who thinks
that this this leadership
race should continue we have i mean i
have a degree i've said it already have
a degree of sympathy for boris johnson
because he's not allowed
constitutionally to do anything fiscally
between now and the fifth of september
so we are in many people's opinions this
rudderless ship and of course there
might well be uh ministers and civil
servants not according to jacob
rees-mogg they're all at home there
might be some still working but those
decisions to to handle money
one thing for you gemma um this 400 quid
this will go down like a lead balloon um
it goes to everybody uh those the
hardest off get more but why are we
giving 400 quid to millionaires why are
we not giving more to the jams and the
people who are struggling to make ends
meet and then people say you can't you
can't talk about means testing just but
you can can't you well well and also it
gets even worse than that because the
payment goes to the person that's on the
the they're named on the utility bill so
people that have multiple homes are
going to get multiple payments and
people that are renting are going to
have to like rely on the goodwill of
their landlord so landlords that again
have multiple properties can also keep
it and i'm quite interested about that
mechanism because people say to me well
it's the easiest way so i'm not having a
go sooner will get twelve hundred quid
because he's got three houses and
somebody who's poverty struck struck you
know just doesn't can't afford anything
we'll get 400 quid to me that's not well
thought out and i and i you know just
very quickly to finish i mean we do this
every night and i'm delighted to have
you on is there any constructive advice
you can give people at this time in
terms of utilities absolutely
constructive devices don't just not pay
because um missed payments and being in
default and in debt it can affect credit
scores and things like that so what i
would say is there are six things i'll
run through quickly that utility
providers should do first of all they
should review your payments to make sure
it's affordable secondly they can reduce
the payments if they're not thirdly give
you more time fourth they have give you
access to hardship funds fifth they can
give you advice on how to use less less
energy and water and finally um if not
if you're vulnerable they should be able
to give extra support as well so that's
this is of course all constructive if
you can get through on the phone to them
um but whether you can or not uh
literally uh we wanted to start with
this tonight it's it's affecting
everybody angela knight former chief
executive energy uk and gemma godfrey
financial expert back tomorrow in the
studio both of you thank you so much
indeed uh for taking part tomorrow night
actually we can talk about uh the cost
crisis continues an expert panel will
break down the impact on the nhs amid
severe warnings today of a staffing
emergency a backlog of cancelled
operations and a surge this is
unbelievable in diy dentistry this is
2022. there are people taking their own
teeth out because they can't get a
dental appointment unbelievable right
next to an uncensored liz trust foreign
secretary and front runner in the tory
leadership and richie sunak live from
those hustings in darlington only here
on talk tv we're coming right back
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh welcome back my friends now we've
looked absolutely everywhere and we just
can't find it we've scoured the streets
we've scaled the hills we've scanned the
skies we've retraced all of our last
steps all of us here have emptied our
pockets we've turned the sock drawer
inside out and we've even scraped around
in that crusty bit at the back of the
sofa ladies and gentlemen the british
government cannot be found britain is a
rudderless ship a plane without a pilot
a homing pigeon with no home do you like
that boris johnson is still the pm but
he can't do anything because he's about
to be kicked out and apparently nobody
else can do anything because the
conservative party hasn't decided who's
going to move in whoever does though get
into number 10 on the 5th of september
will be entering the house of horrors
and i'm not talking about carrie's
golden wallpaper the entree for
britain's next prime minister looks like
the leaning tower of pisa inflation
heading for 13 a war in europe four
million waiting for surgeries a migrant
crisis in the channel we've got no
trains no dentists no water apparently
and even piers morgan's on strike and
looming large above it all the big theme
of our show this week of course the cost
of living crisis that's hammering each
and every one of us and it's happening
now today not in september i'm beginning
to wonder why either liz or rishi even
want the job never mind what they're
going to do with they get it tonight we
might just find out both contenders are
currently speaking to talk tv's matinee
idol tom newton done at a husting
showdown in darlington who wrote that in
just a moment we're here live from front
runner liz but first here's what rushi
sunak had to say earlier
what i won't do
is pursue policies that risk making
inflation worse and last far longer
especially
if those policies
simply amount to borrowing tens and tens
of billions of pounds putting them on
the country's credit card and asking our
kids and our grandkids to pick up the
tab
in a moment we'll be crossing to
darlington where tom newton done will be
speaking to liz truster's december first
let's speak to jesus journalists marina
perkins and emma webb ladies welcome i'm
going to start with you marine you're
going to love this richie sudak the
gloves are off has just said and i quote
boris johnson was responsible for his
own downfall because he lied to the
government that's what that's what cenax
just said enabled by cynic and the rest
of them though i actually feel like well
done tonight you're actually saying
something there but let's not forget he
was loyal with him until the point when
it wasn't you know beneficial to him and
then he cut his ties these lot they're
about they're as loyal as their options
as their career options i wouldn't trust
a single one of them uh really
interesting uh welcome lovely to see you
um
sunax campaign's quite interesting
to me it's not been proactive it's been
reactive i know about the problems with
with liz trust but seemingly with sunak
he sort of got the mps behind him looked
like he thought it was a cate walk and
then has sort of panicked and he's
coming out i mean that's a massive thing
for him to now be criticizing boris
johnson who's criticized by everybody
but as marina quite rightly said
he lived off his coattails for years and
then did what he did and i said and we
haven't spoken since for for many
reasons but i always thought that the
person who actually did the dirty would
never be trusted by the tory faithful
would they never i think it's
interesting because one of the issues
that is exposed at stake here for the
conservative party is an issue of trust
and so in many ways rishi sunak is very
close to boris johnson he is he is
perceived as being very close to a lot
of the scandals that unfolded around
that particular government and that
particular cabinet and what i find very
interesting about this is that
it almost
in and in many ways this is another
problem that the conservatives face is
that it takes the the voters for granted
in a way it seems to at least
portrays the appearance that the uh
electorate are being taken for being
stupid that we can see through that
people can see that this um that this is
a career politician at work well this is
what i would really love and i know
tom's gonna stand by just to to talk to
liz trust i i don't know if politicians
understand the depth of misery worry and
concern in this country more than half
of households this is a fact will be
plunged into fuel poverty by january
that is half of the people living in
this country now much as this race in my
humble opinion has gone on far too long
i don't i'm going to hear about tax cuts
and tax rises and i'm doing this and i'm
doing that and i'm going to support the
great spotted owl competition what about
the people as i said earlier who are
literally literally not going to able to
pay what they apparently owe whilst
these fat cats are making billions it
doesn't work does it jeremy they aren't
the people voting in the next pm this is
what happens when you've got two pm
candidates who are basically speaking to
0.3 of the electorates who aren't the
ones that are going to be hit the
hardest from this cost of living crisis
so they don't need to they don't need to
speak to them i don't need to appeal to
them but they do forget that you know
the rest of us we're watching and we can
see that your measures that you're
forced being forced into proposing is
like having your house on fire and
chucking a bottle of evian over it it's
if they go nowhere near far enough and
as you touched upon earlier it's
nothing's targeted they are wasting so
much money so this trust with her
proposed national income
reversal
that's going to cost 13 billion the
treasury 13 billion pounds
six of every seven pounds of that
goes towards higher um income or higher
income earners basically it's a complete
they're not they're not thinking this
through this it's called like just
boring lack of joy thinking it looks
like it's made up on the hoof i think
listen my my colors are out liz trust
will end up in turn down the street soon
i will never be trusted he's at it again
though i've just heard amir this is
brilliant see like opened up tonight by
saying i declare war on those lefties i
against all this woke we're canceling
our history and we're cancelling our
women he's he's got he's got more
circles than a bag of pretzels this man
doesn't need to be fair he said change
what's that all about the public consent
sincerity and i think the issue here and
i go back to the point about career
politicians is that people can sense
when a politician is taking a position
because they believe that is politically
advantageous to do so and that's what
rishi sunak lacks whereas in in most
cases i think liz trust really does have
a political philosophy and does for the
most part believe in what she's saying
however the issue really here is that
these two candidates that are going to
be presented to the public are not the
candidates that the tory membership
wanted they're not the mem the the
members choice the member's choice was
between penny morden and kami badanok
and kemi badanov being a very principled
politician with a political philosophy
and so i think actually that there's a
real deep problem in our politics and
that our parties across the board do not
represent the electorate and that that
is going to cause trust problems across
the board from a much much uh you know
look further down the road than just
this leadership election marina if
you're you're right both are tainted by
association with boris johnson you've
heard my conspiracy theory he'll become
the envoy to ukraine for two years and
then come back when it's a hung
parliament can be better not i i thought
did such a great job in those those
leadership um campaigns and and and was
real and and and something new and and
for you i mean you'd have them all gone
i get that but
and i listen more than anything and i
get told i know nothing constitutionally
i'm very much with you marina how a
hundred and eighty thousand people
paying 25 quid to be a tory member can
decide on the next prime minister or
government in this country and i know
the manifesto was about the tory party
but that was blatantly ignored boris
johnson got 14 million votes i've always
believed that if you get rid of your
your leader and you you shouldn't
install them in number 10 there should
be a there should be an election oh no
that doesn't work like that well how
does it work when 70 million people are
looking like a bunch of privileged
tories going well why you're all
deciding for me and i can't afford my
bills it's not a great look and i
actually think that this this cost of
living crisis and this
taking the electorate for granted is
going to cast the tories into the
wilderness for years and my fear is that
horrible woman up north is going to
start isn't she that what's her name
nicola sturgeon she'll be in power in a
minute what's going to happen if you if
you were a scot wouldn't you want to be
breaking away from this lot i'm quite
happy if they want to break away but
don't start me on her because she annoys
me don't start me ignore her apparently
why do you not think so what's she got
to do with anything she doesn't want to
be part of this country and spends her
entire time criticizing it she's telling
everybody trying to break away well let
her go then she's being denied the
opportunity by conservative prime
ministers
do you think she's important i love what
liz trusted you so she's of absolutely
no importance or interest to me that's
pierre boris speaker isn't it nice
someone she is a democratically elected
first minister of scotland yeah she's a
democratically elected leader of
scotland who asked for a referendum got
it and the scottish people said no shut
up and deal with it because that's the
fact not you huh it was almost 10 years
ago jeremy why do you want another one
do you understand how many broken
promises yeah but you're one of those
people that would have had 47 years how
should this generation one one vote but
what they were told what they the scots
were promised by the the conservative
government that they were told to they
would stay in the eu for example they
were told there'll be this northern
powerhouse rail and you know what
everything was all scrapped their
welfare was
welfare system was scrapped not scrapped
but lowered they have had broken promise
art broken are you are you a nicholas
sturgeon fan i'm not a nicola oh look i
don't dislike her i'm not in the game
really but all i think is the scots
should be allowed another referendum
because so much has changed what do you
think i actually think that this is one
point where i am absolutely behind liz
trust i don't think that scottish should
be allowed it's not a union then it's
it's prison no because they voted in
2014
to be a part of the united kingdom and
that means that they are subject to the
democratic decisions of the united
states that they would stay within the
european union was supposed to be a wave
in a generation vote we cannot have a
situation constitutionally where we have
parts of the eu parts of the it wouldn't
be accepted in the us it wouldn't be
accepted in places like canada for
example where um quebec wanted
independence at one point or catalan in
spain it wouldn't be accepted that the
parts of a country would keep getting to
vote on their membership of that country
over and over again it's not it's not an
example again we're talking about liz
trust who is like miss sovereignty hell
bent on sovereignty was so pro you know
exiting the european union denying the
scots the opportunities
trust was the remains actually
flip-flopped and you said actually
yes exactly she's flip-flops but now but
now because she's a career politician
she'll go wherever she needs to go
i in fact i find it interesting you say
she's probably the person that's got you
know conviction can we can we love your
business can we agree on one thing um
whoever gets into number 10 as i said
it's going to be uh
an incredibly difficult job a fragmented
country a government whose record has
been tainted by a lot of the things that
went on most importantly the start of
the show tonight a cost of living crisis
that is cutting deep to all levels of
people and and i
personally am you know
people that pro this and pro that i
think right now
you know at this moment in time with
still four weeks to go
one of these people list trust rishi
sunnah needs to understand that the
people of this country are on their
knees they do not understand what's
coming next and they need some i don't
know there's some advice they need
somebody to come out and speak about it
and tell them it'll be okay because
right now
many many many people do not think it's
okay and it's all well and good to play
politics we're talking about real life
right if you two are happy to stay uh
let's cross now to talk tv's tom newton
dunn oh just been told couple of secs
okay he's with foreign secretary and
tory leadership front runner tom and
brilliant no it's not richie's sooner
take a listen
that's what i did as chancellor and
that's what i'll do as prime minister
[Applause]
tom sat there timing is the essence of
great comedy uh liz trust who is the
lead i have to say to you very quickly
before liz comes out still the polls
show she's 60 40 in front of cine i know
you don't want any of them but do you
see you see liz trust winning
i want her to win i think out of the two
i would prefer her to win because i
think she will be a gift to the
opposition if they can get their act
together a gift to the opposition
there's a question for you right
genuinely um we're in the worst economic
crisis this country's seen for years uh
we've got a government that's just
thrown out as prime minister for being a
liar and you're you're talking about us
going and looking at the labour party
here we go uh liz trust tom newton's
only live and talk to you vegan thank
you
thank you succeed
uh let's welcome stage
let's get straight to the big story of
the day i think it's a big story of the
entire contest uh the cost of living and
those energy bills now rishi siege has
just told me he's prepared to match the
sort of generosity he showed in may uh
with direct support govern money
straight to people's bank accounts to
help them pay bills to the tune of
billions come the autumn will you do the
same thing
what i want to do
is make sure first of all we're reducing
taxes because that is needed to drive
economic growth
currently the country is predicted to go
into a recession that will be a huge
problem we know what recessions are like
people lose their jobs there are fewer
opportunities
wages are lower and we need to avoid
that
and at the moment we have the highest
taxes in 70 years so what i would do is
immediately reverse the national
insurance rise i'd also have a temporary
moratorium on the green energy levy to
save people money on fuel bills i do
that from day one but also what i would
do is keep corporation tax low because
we cannot tax our way to growth and i
believe in conservative economics i
believe in a growing economy and a
growing economy actually brings in more
tax revenue in the future so that's a
really fundamental principle for me now
we are facing great difficulties with
energy and i understand people are
struggling with their bills on fuel and
food but the first thing we should do as
conservatives is help people have more
of their own money what i don't support
is taking people
taking money off people in tax and then
giving it back to them in handouts that
to me is gordon brown economics
and
you know
frankly we had
we had we had years of that under labour
and what we got was a slow growth
economy and we didn't get the
opportunities we didn't get the
enterprises we didn't get the new jobs
in places like darlington which is one
of the reasons people voted conservative
they voted conservative because they
want to see enterprise they want to see
new opportunities and that is why it's
so important that we don't raise taxes
that we keep taxes low and also we
abolish these eu rules that are holding
back investment into our country we'll
get on to that let me just clarify
gordon brown economics you're accusing
rishi sunak of having gordon brown
economics what i'm saying is that yes or
no well
if you i was actually responding to your
question tom
which is what i'm here for which is what
i'm here for
which is
which is you know do you just
do you just think about there's a fixed
pie we have to share out the pie and we
have to give out money and handouts my
view is we can grow the pie that there
is a having lower taxes actually helps
us generate more income into the economy
so there is more money to go round and
what i fundamentally don't agree with is
putting up taxes and then also giving
out benefits i think that's the wrong
approach okay
now here's the thing with tax cuts and
you know these numbers as well what
you're proposing that the next cut
stopping the rise
again saves people about 170 pounds a
year stopping the green levees 153
pounds a year as a total of 323 pounds a
year now energy bills
according to today's predictions are
going up to 4 400 pounds a year next
april they're currently at 1 900 that's
where the price gap is so with your
giveaways without your handouts you just
put it you're you're leaving just wait
for the question liz
this is the problem with the way that
every question is framed well
excuse me for framing the question my
way but can i just frame it this way
you're doing it you're flaming in a
left-wing wave tom i'm afraid the whole
media does this all the time
we're all left-wing stooges and you're
trying to count down the clock let me
put the question to you you're leaving
with your tax cuts people some two
thousand pounds out of pocket i ask you
again are you prepared to help them with
government money call them grants call
them support call them handouts at any
stage in your premiership for them to
pay those energy bills well i think the
important
word in your sentence was today that is
the prediction today this leadership
election is about who is going to be the
prime minister in september and what's
important is the prime minister at the
time and the chancellor looks at the
situation
and of course my first priority is
reducing taxes i think it's important
people keep more of their own money and
it's important we grow the economy and
we avoid recession my second priority
is dealing with the supply issue and the
number one thing we can do to end this
energy crisis is to stand up to vladimir
putin in ukraine because that is what is
causing the global price spike and that
is why it's so important we are
investing in defense and we're doing all
we can to stop vladimir putin
and i also want to make sure we're
exploiting all of the gas reserves
and the capacity we have in the uk so we
should be fracking this is important tom
because there are three
let me go on to the three
the three things give me three things
let me know
but but it is important we increase the
supply of energy and there are more
resources to be used in the north sea
there is more we can do on nuclear and
there's more we can do on fracking we
should do all of those things
but of course
in any budget the chancellor has to look
at the situation people are facing
across the country and that decision
not ruling out handouts am i right i'm
not i am not going to say
in the middle of august what is going to
be in a budget later this year but what
i am saying philosophically
is i always favor people keeping more of
their own money first what i think is
completely wrong is the idea that we
take huge sways of people's money
hard-working people and then give it
back to them and then then claim it's a
giveaway and it's our money that is
completely wrong
that's completely wrong tom and i don't
believe in it okay
for the record you didn't rule out
handouts i wonder if it was a handout
when registered did it in may that 15
billion but i think we've done enough on
handouts as you call them the cbi
address general tony danker i put this
question to rishi soon like a minute
back uh he wants you rishi sunak and
boris johnson to get into a room agree a
policy right now to help people pay
those bills not on the 6th of september
when you get into office on the 21st of
september which apparently when your
emergency party is going to be right now
would you agree and do you want to get
into that room with rishi boris tomorrow
well first of all i am foreign secretary
and i'm focusing my energy on dealing
with the very serious foreign policy
issues we face
the issues in taiwan
the issues with russia and ukraine and
that is rightly my focus we have a
chancellor nadim zahawi we have a prime
minister who are in those jobs until
september and i think it would be
constitutionally deeply undesirable to
try and overrule them with a sort of
made-up committee of the cbi me and
rishi zunak
i mean i just find
i find it an extraordinary
you know
that is a harwi
not not just he's not just because he's
a supporter of my campaign and he is um
is a fantastic chap
boris johnson has done a great job as
prime minister delivering brexit
delivering
delivering on the covered vaccine
standing up to putin they are capable
people capable of making these decisions
this kangaroo committee you're proposing
sounds bizarre okay
[Applause]
it was
tony danke and gordon brown proposing it
not me for the record list
sorry you're gonna go to golden again
let me ask you about uh something quite
serious again something i put to
mississippi i'm really interested in
your views on state spending is not
immune to inflation inflation could pass
13 quite soon that means government
budgets are going to need a lot more
money spent on them are you prepared to
keep the nh budget where it is now in
real terms in other words spend quite a
bit more money keeping spending in real
terms where it is now well just to be
clear i am committed to the additional
spending on the nhs the 13 billion i
want more of it to go into social care i
want more of it to go directly to
councils which question well it is
answering the question because that is
the nhs budget and i do think the nhs
budget will have to continue to go up in
real terms but i'm not
going to pre-judge the spending review
which i want to be committed alongside
the budget all right let me ask you
something that's been rumored is it true
your team are in open access talks
already with the cabinet office about
what your premiership looks like
no that's not true okay thank you for
cleaning that one up i want to ask you
about your character and johnny okay uh
let's trust there with tom newton let's
get back to jesus journalist emma webb
and maria can i try this out to both of
you list trust we've got the highest
taxes in 70 years i'm going to cut the
green levy keep corporation tax low
because you can't tax to grow i'm going
to frack i'm going to increase nuclear
power i'm going to spend more on social
care support the nhs my question very
simply to you is
where was all of that when she was in
boris johnson's cabin or am i missing
the point
you're not missing the point she voted
for all of those tax increases by the
way she voted 15 times for them in the
last two years jeremy so
those things rishi as well he was in
power he is the person that put these
policies in place but even so if we just
distill what she's talking about here
it's nonsense it's almost like a feeding
but is it pieces of bullseye robbing
peter to pay paul but it doesn't work
what i hate is how she's trying to use
the term handouts in a derogatory way to
make people feel ashamed or it's a bad
thing what's good about handouts if you
want to call it that is that they they
are targeted tax cuts all tax cuts to
you by the way is put more money in the
pockets of the
more wealthy people and then you've got
that
which isn't going to what impact
inflation when the bank of england is
then working opposite that to try and
increase interest rates to try and curb
inflation it doesn't work emma it seems
to me to be a bounty of promises
promises that were in the manifesto
which were blatantly ignored whilst
johnson was in power but then we're
going to talk about the pandemic we're
going to talk about the problems of
brexit i'm sort of with marina in that
there's a
i'm not sure how sort of genuine i feel
that all of these promises are i i just
you know she said i'm foreign secretary
yeah you are but you're at a hustings
almost on a daily basis and having a
debate on every television channel i
don't see you doing anything on tawan or
anywhere else i think you're
concentrating on getting to number 10.
she poo poo tom's idea about an
emergency budget right now what's she
what's your thought on that because the
cbi say we need to act now not in six
weeks i i i'm not sure what my my
thoughts are on an emergency budget i do
think something needs to happen now and
i think that now is a very very bad time
for the conservatives to be having a
leadership election i think
fundamentally going back to what you
were saying is that
part of the problem here is that
even though liz trust is my favorite
candidate she's very scripted in the way
that she delivers her answers and that
doesn't strike a chord of authenticity
and going back to kemi badanok who was
my preferred candidate when kenny
badenock speaks she yes but i think that
she's a good example of what a
politician should be but she's somebody
that marina is right she's not in the
game we have got two people tainted if
you like by johnson association who are
making promises that were made in the
manifesto three years ago and and you
know i i we don't share the same
politics but i'm talking about people
watching this tonight are going to go
but you said all that before you talked
about social care you talked about
why would i think it and i the thing
that enrages me i i think liz trust will
win
i think that she will not give sunak a
job uh i think that the tory party will
be an open warfare but i'll make the
point again to you that i was cut off as
i said to liz trust your party with the
greatest of respect with with open
warfare and the tories losing seats left
right and center thrown out their prime
minister they're not getting any
traction nobody in this country trusts
the labour party specifically because
they still believe that the labour party
isn't fit to govern that is true isn't
it why are you not right ahead in the
polls they should be
not my party well you know i would just
say i will vote for whoever i need to to
deceive the tory and my constituency and
i implore other people to do the same
you can answer the question though why
isn't star streets ahead come on i
actually think starmer has has missed so
many open goals and i am really getting
disappointed with it's about as exciting
as that glasses it doesn't resonate does
it care for someone to be exciting i'm
quite happy with gordon brown he could
step back into the room when he was in
power he wasn't very good was he i think
he was a bit too young to even remember
remember what was going
old
i remember everything me
they should be ahead but i also think
you need to bear in mind in my eye this
isn't the place to talk about it but the
media skewer the left if there is
anything going on like
kissed alma 12 front pages in the daily
mail for a
non-illegal
curry and a beer and yet you've got
boris johnson don't start me on that
because
we'll we'll we'll
we'll disagree a beer and a curry in a
house with 30 people and a piece of cake
on the way to a meeting in your office
with 12.
that's wrong and you can i'll tell you
what i think wrong is getting rid of a
prime minister for a piece of cake but
he got rid because he was rid of because
of pincher well even more ridiculous
kenny bad knock out of the game liz
trust rishi sooner you both say liz
trust wowzers you both say liz trust yes
i i will be voting for this trust uh if
you had to vote come on trust because
it's awful right two years down the line
um a hung parliament stammer still
doesn't get through to the british
electorate bit of a hung party and and
that woman from scotland could could
hold the balance of power a woman who
doesn't want to be associated with this
country
it's a nightmare isn't it and you know
it's a nightmare and it's the making of
what who made this 12 years of tory
government can i just ask people if
you're not happy with things right try
something new but there isn't an
alternative is there really well where
is the alternative well what's the
alternative do you think it would happen
to the country if if kierstama's labour
did get into power what do you what do
you think i think we probably rejoined
the eu in time but let's agree to
disagree uh emma webb uh marina perkins
i love you both thank you for being on
that's jesus next on unsensitive here's
an exclusive could the fbi's raid and
former president donald trump's uh
troubles uh trump trump's uh florida
resort oh goodness help him in 2024 i'll
be asking his former man uh senior
to president trump jason miller he's
here after that president trump we're
coming right back don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there you are my friends welcome back
now before the break you were witnessing
my greatest tv humiliation i described
him as a donald trump president trump
and not to uh
a figure from a children's television
program one day in the future right
in the future this is true the heads of
the justice department and the fbi will
no doubt be brought to capitol hill to
testify about the historic decision to
raid a former president's home you see
late last night trump's private
residence was raided now we don't yet
know too much about what was in that
search warrant but we do know that the
rage concern the removal of classified
documents from the white house that
trump allegedly took with him when he
left office last year this is what trump
said in the statement i love this these
are dark times for our nation as my
beautiful home in palm beach florida is
currently under siege raided and
occupied by a large group of fbi agents
nothing like this has ever happened to a
president of the united states before
such an assault could only take place in
broken third world countries sadly
america has now become one of those
countries corrupted a level not seen
before they even broke in to my safe
so what was in that safe i'm joined now
by president trump's former senior
adviser
jason miller how are you jason jeremy
good to be with you i'm sorry about my
inability to say his name um let's cut
to the chase how long did you work with
donald trump so i worked for the
president both the 2016 campaign and the
2020 campaign in them for about five or
six months after he left office quite
possibly the most
divisive uh
a light johnson but on a far greater
scale loved and loathed in equal measure
i remind people in this country that 74
million people voted for him in the last
election now currently under
investigation over the capitol hill riot
uh last week we saw a situation where
nancy pelosi went to taiwan apparently
nothing to do with biden last night um
the fbi raid an ex-president's
residence
biden's hand in this or no i don't think
biden directly this is not going to help
biden if anything it's going to backfire
but i do think that it's a political
appointees that joe biden has put at the
doj and other places that had a hand in
this i mean the fact that this happened
that we've never had something like this
in american history this is what happens
in venezuela or cuba or with the ccp in
china
we're now a laughingstock of the world
and what we're doing for political
retribution you talk about political
retribution presumably um from this side
of the pond i would look at it and go
they're doing everything they can to
prove that he broke the law which means
he won't be able to stand for public
office would that be fair that's
absolutely true that's what we're seeing
with the january 6 hearings that's what
we're seeing with this uh effort with
the uh the fbi agents doing their raid
last night's what we see with the
democrats on capitol hill going after
his tax returns they're going to do
everything they can to stop them for
2024. what a lot of folks might not
realize he's leading in the primary
president trump is and also a lot of
polls show him leading joe biden so joe
biden's in a pretty bad place right now
and donald trump is setting up for a
victory
that's why i think the deep state that's
why i think the bureaucracy they're
coming after them with everything they
have it's interesting though isn't it
you said to me during the break that
i said is he going to stand i think
he'll stand what do you think do you
think it's time because you said after
last night
the republicans are absolutely raging
absolutely i think the before last night
i'd say was maybe the 60 40 maybe 70 30
range i think after last night i think
it's almost certain that president trump
runs again and i think the reason being
is he realizes that once you start
attacking the swamp once you start
trying to change things they're never
going to stop shooting at you isn't it
true to say that that any candidate that
would try and take that nomination from
him would need his
acceptance his support he has this
amazing uh control over the republican
party but what would you say to the
critics who say he left office in
disgrace i mean i read something today
apparently flushed every evidence down
the the toilet you don't say toilet i
don't know what you're saying whatever
uh bathroom uh apparently there is
indeed the very toilet that president
trump allegedly uh flushed evidence down
it just
man to man you and me is he as devious
is he as duplicitous as everybody makes
out what's the real man you know the
real man i do i think he's one of the
things is he's the exact same off camera
as he is on and i'll tell you that's
different from any other politician i've
ever worked with and i've done that for
much of the last 20 almost 30 years
you always know where you stand with
trump there's no guessing game he'll
tell you their face there have been
plenty of times he said jason this is
great ideas plenty of times where he
said this is a terrible idea there's
never a guessing game but the thing
about him going and running i think a
lot of people forget this point not only
does he have a firm grip of the
republican base right now keep in mind
in 2020 he actually set the modern
record for votes with hispanic americans
african-americans asian-americans for
republican best ever since 1972 i don't
think that there's another republican
that can win in blue states democrat
states the same way that trump can does
he demand total loyalty there was
something in the newspaper i read the
wicked
you know he's he new york times i think
said you know he demands his general
support him it was just this
extraordinary rhetoric i mean
again from this side of the pond you
know he he sacked almost everybody all
the time and yet
leaves office okay left office didn't
win made a big thing about that did he i
mean there's so much that it sounds a
terrible thing to say fascinating about
this man but but if if you look at what
happened we're sat here and we're saying
if there was an election in the united
states of america tomorrow he would be
the next president of the united states
what does that say about the american
people but it says the american people
they at the time in 2020 they were told
that if you just stop tweeting mean
things if we just restore sensibility
and a really nice guy like uncle joe
everything is going to go back to
normalcy in the world we're not going to
have invasions uh we're not going to
have a crisis out or southern border
there'll be no inflation well guess what
the exact opposite has happened i want
to go back to a point that you said a
moment ago about the the absolute
loyalty because i i think if you're
trying to understand what trump is about
if you're in the room with him you're
expected to have an opinion he'll go
around doesn't mean it matter you're the
most senior person the most junior
person he'll look in your eye say what's
your opinion on this position he's fine
if someone stands up and says no i think
you're wrong if you have a good idea or
a solution to go forward if you're it's
easy for someone who works for a
politician to say no but if you have
nothing to back it up then he'll tell
you to get lost he's box office isn't he
i mean he's he's one of those people
that as i said at the beginning of our
chat jason demands 100 loyalty you love
him or you loathe him so let's say
stands you think he will i think i think
so and if he if he wins will the call
come to jason miller will you go back
and work with him again oh the call will
come before he actually wins it will be
to help him i've already told him if he
runs i'll be there to help him
absolutely i'm always his number one
biggest wingman and i'm ready to go into
battle again do you think that um the
american people can forgive january the
6th do you think enough of them uh can
put that behind them because we haven't
got long
you're right again from this side of the
pond joe biden's been a huge
disappointment kamala harris has
disappeared out of view
so that's a really smart question
because there's always the matchup are
you going to go with the joe biden who
tanked the economy allowed putin to roll
into ukraine china just a matter of
minutes i'm guessing until they took
over taiwan maybe it's by the end of
this show you stack that up against what
trump was able to do people say you know
what we can go and we're going to pick
how does it impact me in my family
that's what all comes down to the
pocketbook look the wealth disparity uh
is still getting bigger and bigger
people the inflation not just hurting
folks here in the uk really crushing
people in the u.s they're like hey i'm
not going to say that what happened on
january 6 should be swept under the rug
it was a terrible day for america and
but the bad actors the people who had
planned and plotted this thing they
weren't part of a trump movement the
trump agenda he has no time for the
lawlessness and the craziness those if
you broke a law if you assaulted someone
very very quickly could he have been
more vocal in criticizing and trying to
stop it that's the question surely sure
and do i think it fundamentally would
have changed the outcome on that day no
could he have spoken out earlier uh i do
think so so if you if he wins in 2024
and you get a job you'll come back on
the show will you i'll always come back
a real pleasure seriously i'd love to
have had more time jason miller uh that
raid last night on on donald trump's
home uh jason says and this is really
interesting will galvanize galvanize the
republicans behind trump he said to us
just then you know before last night
maybe 60 40 jason is convinced that
donald trump will stand again in 2024
and judging judging by what we see in
the polls not only would he stand he'll
win maybe johnson will come make a
comeback listen thank you so much indeed
for watching tonight uh we've got there
eventually thank you to tom newton and
liz trust that's it for me just remember
wherever you are keep it uncensored have
a great night we'll see you tomorrow
night
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers alan in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the beast this simply does not wash look
who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zara sullivan liz truss
and rushi sunek have clashed over
support for the cost of living crisis at
the latest hustings it's been revealed
that the government is planning
blackouts and gas cuts in a reasonable
worst case scenario this winter
ryan giggs's ex-girlfriend has told the
court if she wasn't a good girl he would
get angry and not be very nice to her
kate greville claimed the former
footballer who's facing several charges
including two counts of assault cheated
on her with eight other women whilst
they were together he denies all charges
against him
and tim's water says they'll impose a
hosepipe ban in the next few weeks the
uk's bracing for another heat wave and
amble warnings been issued this week
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you